monsieur le président cher gérard
larcher que la maison messieurs nous
voilà donc réunis pour mettre en place
une conférence nationale des territoires
cette conférence a été proposée par le
président de la république
elle a un objectif simple qu aucune
décision affectant les collectivités
locales ne soient prises sans y être
discuté elle porte un enjeu plus
compliqué sortir du face à face parfois
stérile souvent méfiants entre l'état
les collectivités territoriales elles
portent en vérité un défi immense
continuer le chemin et peut-être même à
certains égards ouvrir la voie nous
permettant d'aboutir à une
décentralisation pleinement assumé agile
et pour tout dire intelligente
il est heureux monsieur le président du
sénat que nous puissions le faire ici
justement au sénat et je voudrais
remercier très sincèrement et très
chaleureusement
gérard larcher ainsi que l'ensemble des
sénateurs qui nous accueillent
aujourd'hui si nous pouvons le faire ici
et je dirais même monsieur le président
si nous devons le faire ici d'abord
c'est parce que le sénat ce rôle si
particulier d'abord aux termes de
l'article 24 de la constitution il
assure la représentation des
collectivités territoriales de la
république et ensuite ses membres sont
des élus élus par des élus et à ce titre
ils portent presque
par nature les collectivités
territoriales leurs intérêts leurs
préoccupations leurs difficultés parfois
notre objectif sera évidemment d'écouté
et de discuter en évitant
systématiquement les concurrencer les
compétitions qui peuvent exister entre
l'ensemble de ceux qui légitimement
porte les intérêts des collectivités
territoriales de certaines strates de
ces collectivités territoriales de
certaines catégories
de ces collectivités territoriales et le
sénat merci donc monsieur le président
de nous y avoir accueilli et d'accepter
de coprésider cette première réunion
il était heureux que nous puissions le
faire non seulement ici mais en mettant
j'allais dire autour de la table mais en
tout cas
imaginons une table tous les acteurs de
ce défi collectif l'état d'abord bien
entendu l'état représenté ici par de
nombreux membres du gouvernement qui
interviendront au fur et à mesure de la
matinée et de la journée et qui auront
l'occasion d'expliquer nos nos objectifs
les représentants désignés par les
associations représentant les
collectivités territoriales régions les
départements les communes et les
intercommunalités les présidents des
instances permanente de concertation le
comité des finances locales le conseil
supérieur de la fonction publique
territoriale conseil d'évaluation des
normes et bien entendu des représentants
du parlement assemblée nationale et
sénat
là encore à travers cette représentation
nous souhaitons permettre à chaque
territoire dans toute la diversité qu'il
représente d'être entendu qu'ils soient
isolés ou lointain qu'ils soient
représentants de la densité urbaine ou
au contraire d'une périphérie qu'il le
serait moins qu'ils le soient des
territoires que l'on présente trop
souvent et qui se vivent parfois comme
des territoires ddt interstices entre
deux zones très denses je pense
notamment aux petites villes ou aux
villes moyennes qu'il porte des
caractéristiques qui au delà de leur
taille ou de leur situation géographique
soit très particulière je pense par
exemple aux territoires de montagne je
pense au moins autant aux territoires
littoraux aux territoires touristiques
ou aux territoires frontaliers et il y
en a bien entendu beaucoup d'autres qui
portent des logiques et des contraintes
particulière pour réussir cette
conférence nationale du territoire je
vous propose cinq chantiers une méthode
ces cinq sentiers c'est d'abord pour le
premier d'entre eux la question des
structures nous voulons l'aborder cette
question des structures sous l'angle des
libertés il ne s'agit pas d'imposer ou
de modifier une architecture globale des
collectivités territoriales est
certainement encore moins de l'imposer
depuis paris
il s'agit d'essayer dans toute la mesure
du possible de laisser la liberté aux
territoires d'adapter leurs structures
aux réalités locales par des fusions de
communes ou des fusions de départements
ou par la prod l'approfondissement du
fait métropolitain
là où ce sera souhaité localement et
quand ce sera dans l'intérêt général
gérard collomb ministre d'état ministre
de l'intérieur présentera notre optique
sur cette question de structure mais
j'ai entendu ce que disait monsieur le
président du sénat l'objectif de liberté
et de stabilité
mais en termes de compétences nous
voulons à la fois permettre aux libertés
locales de s'exprimer tout en conservant
l'idée d'une stabilité globale du
dispositif
le deuxième chantier si celui des
compétences et là encore nous voulons
concilier liberté et stabilité
il ne s'agit pas d'imposer un nouveau
big bang ou de modifier profondément les
équilibres qui ont été construits
précédemment on peut tout à fait penser
qu'à certains égards ils ne sont pas
entièrement satisfaisant mais je crois
que personne n'envisage sérieusement de
les remettre complètement sur le
chantier et d'envisager ce nouveau big
bang que je décrivais pour l'écarter
mais cette stabilité elle peut laisser
la place là encore à la liberté par un
droit à l'expérimentation par un droit
la différenciation par un droit la
délégation et notamment la délégation de
compétence depuis l'état vers les
collectivités territoriales cela existe
déjà depuis des collectivités
territoriales vers d'autres
collectivités territoriales
il nous faut là encore innover
expérimenté faire place à toute cette
liberté
le troisième chantier c'est le chantier
du pacte financier
lille est sensible évidemment car la
question des moyens est évidemment
indispensable pour l'action des
collectivités territoriales vécu comme
un élément d'autonomie et de libre
administration héritière disons le
clairement de nombreux malentendus ou
trop bien entendu entre l'état et les
collectivités territoriales
l'héritière aussi d'un système conçu
bien avant la décentralisation qui a
bien sûr évolué mais dont on peut je
crois dire sans trop se tromper que la
lisibilité l'efficacité et la justice du
dispositif fiscal qui prévaut en matière
de finances locales est aujourd'hui
discutable vous connaissez parfaitement
la situation des finances publiques
vous savez l'évolution des effectifs
dans les trois fonctions publiques
rien de tout cela n'est soutenable
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire lors de ma
déclaration de politique générale
je le redis depuis je leur dirai à
chaque fois qu'il sera nécessaire de le
redire nous devons diminuer notre
montant de dépenses publiques les
collectivités territoriales doivent
prendre leur part à cet effort et cet
effort sera globalement important
plutôt que de parler directement et
spontanément de baisse des dotations
nous devons essayer et c'est un exercice
délicat de trouver un mécanisme assurant
la baisse de la dépense publique
la baisse de l'endettement public plus
intelligemment que par l'imposition
brutale d'une baisse des dotations mais
entendons-nous bien trouver un mécanisme
de pilotage des dépenses publiques y
compris des dépenses publiques locales
plus intelligent que simplement une
baisse des dotations ne veut pas dire
qu'on pourrait contourner l'objectif de
baisse des dépenses
il faudra que nous discutions en
confiance en transparence pour mettre en
place ces mécanismes qui nous
permettront d'arriver un objectif qui
lui ne sera pas discutable
nous devons donner plus de visibilité et
plus de prévisibilité je retrouve vos
mots monsieur le président sur
l'évolution des ressources des
collectivités territoriales et nous
devons engager une réflexion d'ensemble
sur la fiscalité locale sur la taxe
d'habitation bien sûr elle est annoncée
mais plus généralement sur l'ensemble du
système de financement des collectivités
territoriales parce qu'une
décentralisation assumer intelligente
passe par un système de finance local
rénové
je n'ai aucun doute sur le fait que ce
sera dur et aucun doute sur le fait que
ce sera long j'ai d'ailleurs pas
beaucoup de doute non plus sur le fait
que nous trouverons sans doute mille
raisons de nous enliser
mais le système qui prévaut aujourd'hui
et qui garantit à certains égards
l'action des collectivités territoriales
n'est pas un bon système
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire devant le
sénat lors de ma première intervention
il n'est pas un bon système il doit
évoluer et nous devons réfléchir
ensemble à la façon de le faire évoluer
intelligemment gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics présentera dans quelques
instants ce troisième chantier le
quatrième et le cinquième chantier sont
des sentiers d'action publique
non pas d'organisations n'ont pas de
moyens mais de politique publique à
mettre en oeuvre
il concerne la fracture territoriale et
nous voulons faire de la réduction de
cette fracture territoriale une priorité
nationale c'est la raison qui a conduit
le président de la république sous ma
proposition a créé un ministère en
charge de la cohésion des territoires
c'est monsieur jacques mézard bien connu
dans cette maison ainsi que monsieur de
normandie qui auront la charge de
présenter ce quatrième chantier et
d'animer dans le courant de l'après-midi
des ateliers qui sont consacrés à ceux
qui au fond doit nous permettre de
redonner un sens à cette notion à
laquelle nous sommes tous attachés
d'égalité des chances
ça passe par des réflexions sur les
déserts médicaux sur une pensée nouvelle
en matière de mobilité sur des questions
de revitalisation des centres bourgs des
petites villes sur la question
évidemment de la mise en place d'un
dispositif permettant à chacun des
territoires de notre pays d'avoir accès
dans d'excellentes conditions numérique
donc de pouvoir trouver une façon de
s'inscrire dans la transformation du
monde sans y être relégué cinquième
chantier celui des transformations
écologiques et du numérique
il s'agit de préparer d'accompagner ces
transitions qui sont à la fois
inexorable déstabilisante
à bien des égards et en même temps
prometteuse nicolas hulot sébastien
lecornu et mounir majidi animeront des
ateliers présenteront la façon dont nous
devons nous envisageons de discuter avec
les collectivités territoriales de la
mise en place de ces transitions voilà
pour les cinq chantiers qui feront
l'objet des discussions
je voudrais dire un mot enfin de la
méthode c'est à dire de la façon dont
nous pourrions approfondir et discuter
de ces sujets le premier élément je
reprends votre là encore votre
votre mot monsieur le président larcher
qui est un mot qui est un concept qui
est même une invitation c'est celui de
confiance et la confiance nous savons
parfaitement qu'elle ne se décrète pas
qu'elle ne se présume même pas elle peut
au mieux se construire et se démontrer
et pour se construire et montrer il faut
partir d'un bon pied et la renforcer
y compris y compris dans des désaccords
mais en ayant toujours à l'esprit la
nécessité d' échanges réguliers francs
sérieux et assumer cette confiance elle
peut se construire en dépit de
désaccords et d'ailleurs sur les bancs
de toutes les assemblées qu'elles soient
parlementaires ou locales nous savons
qu'il est possible de créer des liens de
confiance en dépit de désaccords
je dirais même parfois avec des
désaccords c'est vrai dans toutes les
intercommunalités
en tout cas c'est c'est particulièrement
vrai dans celle que j'ai eu l'honneur de
présider ou quelles que soient les
appartenances politiques
et quelles que soient les différences
d'intérêt des communes qui étaient
présentes dans l'intercommunalité nous
étions en mesure de créer justement ce
lien de confiance qui permet en dépit de
désaccords d'avancé de créer des
constats communs et d'envisager des
politiques communes j'ai donc un bon
espoir que nous soyons en mesure de
construire cette confiance notre méthode
elle sera organisée autour d'une
instance de dialogue serré c'est celle
qui nous réunit ce matin qui pourrait
tenir des réunions semestrielles avec
justement une façon d'organiser le
travail qui nous permettrait de préparer
ensemble ces réunions de travailler
ensemble sur les sujets qui sont évoqués
et sur la façon dont nous pouvons
avancer de choisir même ensemble les
thèmes qui pourraient être abordés dans
l'intervalle nous envisageons un
processus de travail élargie à d'autres
acteurs nous pouvons par exemple
facilement mettre en place des missions
d'analysé comme une collectivité
territoriale et à des groupes de travail
thématiques sur des politiques publiques
ou un certain nombre de ces thèmes
peut-être que la fin de la matinée nous
permettra de les arrêter ensemble et
puis une réflexion locale
car évidemment tout ne peut pas se
passer au sénat monsieur le président
beaucoup de choses peuvent se passer
mais il faut aussi si nous voulons que
la réflexion soit intense et enracinée
que nous puissions organiser des
sessions dans les régions avec les
représentants de l'état avec les élus
locaux pour discuter un certain nombre
de sujets cette méthode je propose qu'on
l'écrive que l'on conclut un contrat de
méthode j'ai la conviction que lorsqu'on
se met d'accord sur la méthode
on ne s'est pas encore mis d'accord sur
le fond mais que si on ne se met pas
d'accord sur la méthode on ne se mettra
jamais d'accord sur le fond et donc je
vous propose que nous essayons de
conclure ce contrat de méthode en
reprenant ses objectifs
en reprenant ces priorités en reprenant
ses rythmes et ses principes
cela pourrait être là aussi un des
éléments d'arrivée de notre matinée
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs pour présenter d'un mot à la
fois un peu long et sans doute trop bref
l'objectif et les principes ainsi que
les thèmes que nous voulons discuter
pendant cette conférence je vous propose
si vous en êtes d'accord monsieur le
président de commencer sans plus
attendre a évoqué ateliers par atelier
les sujets qui nous rassemble et
peut-être de passer la parole à monsieur
le ministre d'état ministre de
l'intérieur pour qu'il dise un mot sur
la façon dont ils envisagent cette
réflexion sur les structures merci
beaucoup
voilà donc pour les discours du
président du sénat gérard larcher et du
premier ministre edouard philippe le
reste des discussions se déroulera à
huis clos mais nous aurons l'occasion
d'en reparler avec nos invités